[Musica]
poi ho adesso il momento di scendere in
apnea
non c'è spazio per nient'altro anzi non
c'è più nemmeno il ricordo di essere una
persona diversa da quella che ora sta
scendendo in profondità
non si può vivere senza respirare dunque
l'app ne amplifica la vita dilatando
l'intervallo tra quest'ultimo profondo
respiro e il prossimo che io cerco di
portare sempre più lontano nel tempo e
nello spazio
e così che semplici secondi si
trasformano in una preziosa eternità che
vive sotto il cap sotto il mare
in questo viaggio dentro l'assoluto che
compia lungo il cavo questo cavo che
come un cordone ombelicale mi lega la
sopravvivenza indicandomi la strada di
discesa e risalita in questo abisso in
cui ho deciso di calarmi la dimensione
del non respiro e così che l'ho chiamata
entriamoci insieme la vista appannata
l'udito ha votato il tatto limitato la
sensibilità dalle zone scoperte
tutto ciò su cui facciamo affidamento
nella vita terrestre per comprendere ed
esplorare e sospeso
l'attenzione si sposta dall'esterno
all'interno il mare ci libera dai sensi
a noi liberarci dalla nostra identità sa
cosa penso durante il tuffo non penso
non voglio pensare
svuoto la mente per raggiungere la vera
essenza non c'è più chiara dentista
amica compagna nemmeno chiara apneista
solo chiara e in ogni singola discesa ti
trovi ad affrontare questa decisione
voi davvero continuare il tuo viaggio
verso l'ignoto
perché se continui sei obbligato a
lasciati alle spalle una grossa parte di
te la tua storia
i tuoi successi i tuoi rimpianti le sue
preoccupazioni le tue speranze meno di
te ti porti appresso e più leggero sarà
il peso resta solo il tuo io presente
nel momento presente
una volta deciso devi lasciarti cadere
sempre più giù nel mare della tua anima
il piattello e il tuo punto d'arrivo sul
fondo sei un altro in un mondo
straordinariamente diverso e distante
dalla realtà che conosci sai di avere
assolutamente bisogno di questa
dimensione di discesa nell interiorità
serve determinazione per non tradire la
parte di te che vive sotto il mare
e infatti abbiamo scelto di essere i cui
ricordi superficie e profondità sono
confini del mare e della mente e oggi li
hai superati entrambi la risalita questa
è davvero la parte più dura degli aggi è
qui che potrebbe arrivare lo sconforto o
il panico se perdessi il filo conduttore
del percorso mentale ma tu sei
concentrata connessa sai che devi dare
fondo ad ogni risorsa sfoderare la
grinta metro dopo metro
ho fiducia voglio farcela
voglio dare il meglio di me contro le
pinne già te per dare qualcosa in pasto
alla mia mente senza cercare un vero
punto d'arrivo il dolore alle gambe
passa mi dico essenziale conservare la
leggerezza della mente contro la
pesantezza delle gambe
sorridi in risalita penso a sorridere
sembra assurdo ma se sorridi con le
labbra questo terrà la tua mente
agganciata al benessere senza permettere
alla sofferenza di entrare ho scelto di
affrontare questo viaggio di discesa in
profondità per guardarmi dentro per
raggiungere un contatto sempre più
intimo con me stessa
le mie paure le mie tensioni più
profonda le mie aspirazioni più vere per
incontrare i miei limiti mentali e
cercare di farmi gli amici
tutti possiamo farlo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
siamo venuti al mondo trattenendo il
respiro sott'acqua e il nostro inconscio
non l'ha dimenticato
l'app ne è una forma di meditazione e
spontanea naturale che ha il potere di
ricondurci a questa condizione di unione
primordiale in cui davvero mente corpo
affluiscono insieme
l'apnea offre il tempo e lo spazio per
fermarsi e ri scoprire chi sono e chi
sto diventando chi sono ho iniziato a
farmi questa domanda che avevo forse 89
anni e sono scesa fino a cento metri di
profondità per cercare la risposta e
ogni volta che mi sembra di averla
praticamente raggiunta
lei mi tira allo scherzo disposta se
qualche metro più in giù mi chiamo
chiara sono dentista madre di due
bambine il pluri primatista mondiale di
apnea la definizione dell'identità
condizionato il mio percorso sin
dall'inizio ero madre o atleta ero
dentista o apneista le identità limitano
l'agire olo espandono cioè se sono
apneista smetto di essere dentista
oppure posso essere madre professionista
e atleta di vertice senza sentirmi
sempre alla persona sbagliata nel posto
sbagliato
ero scissa e andare verso la divisione
non è mai una buona opzione
dunque cosa potevo fare facciamo un
piccolo passo in avanti nella
costruzione di questo top è stato
fondamentale in focalizzarsi sulle
esigenze di togliere contenuti concetti
parole per rendere il discorso più
fluido e comprensibile doveva condensare
in 8 minuti la moltitudine di cose che
avrei avuto da dire su questo argomento
e credetemi essere efficaci intensi
lasciare un messaggio in così poco tempo
davvero non è semplice
così ragionando su come riuscire in
questo intento ho realizzato per la
prima volta quale speciale attinenza ci
fosse con l'app neo che è appunto
togliere lasciare la superficie per
sperimentare
in profondità bisognava togliere per
comunicare così come bisognava togliere
per sperimentare ma la vera difficoltà è
cosa e come togliere senza tradire
l'identità mia come di questo top
togliere quello che avevo fatto in gran
parte della mia vita ho impiegato del
tempo a trovare la mia strada a capire
cosa avesse il potere di lasciarmi piena
soddisfatta perché si potrebbe pensare
che sia facile per chi come me alla
passione il fuoco dentro
beh non è così o perlomeno non è stato
così da principio ho dovuto cercare in
questo cercare ho dovuto soprattutto
togliere togliere le cose che non mi
interessavano quelle che facevo per
sentirmi come gli altri per piacere
perché si è sempre fatto così
o semplicemente perché non avevo il
coraggio di cambiare e solo dopo è stato
possibile aggiungere il il percorso di
che stavo compiendo era molto simile a
quello che avevo realizzato sott'acqua
stavo iniziando veramente ad utilizzare
quello che avevo imparato in profondità
in superficie togliere non è spogliarsi
disse non è cancellare e piuttosto
asciugare e senza seccare togliere non
era dividere ma riunirà e se non era
dividere ma riunire allora forse la mia
strada non era rinunciare ad una delle
mie identità sarebbe stato sopprimere
una parte troppo importante di me ma
riunirla eccome beh solo per parlare di
questo servirebbe una giornata intera ma
voglio farvi qualche esempio la crescita
dell'identità di un atleta di alto
livello
comprende lo sviluppo di convinzioni
potentissime su se stessi che si basano
sulla presa di consapevolezza dei nostri
punti di forza
si chiamano credenze potenzianti e a
volte possono essere così potenti da
superare i confini dell'identità in cui
si sono formate per radicarsi come
caratteristiche proprie della persona
nel mio caso per esempio
l'atleta determinata che non si arrende
mai diventa anche una madre tenace è una
professionista strutturata soli da di
fronte alle avversità e quest'anno con
le avversità siamo andati alla grande
ho la capacità di connessione con se
stessi e l'attenzione mirata a tipica
del pre gara si trasformano in
disponibilità all'ascolto e apertura al
dialogo che si tratti dei pazienti o dei
figli io non ero l'una o l'altra cosa
non trascurava l'una per l'altra cosa
piuttosto ciascun identità contribuiva a
creare a delineare un processo di
crescita innovativo e molto interessante
perché ciascuna identità è diventata
realmente il luogo in cui si sviluppano
competenze nuove e utili in tutti i
campi dell'agire finalmente non ero più
scissa avevo trovato la strada per
l'unione non soltanto di mente e corpo
ma anche dell'identità la discesa in
apnea che ci permette di riportare in
superficie quelle senza di noi che
abbiamo riscoperto e una fantastica
metafora della vita si può risalire solo
andando a fondo e noi questo fondo
possiamo spostarlo sempre più giù
riemergere ogni volta sarà come
rinascere grazie
[Musica]